When it comes to teenagers, we always get it wrong. Even in the most widely scrutinized, widely reported stories, we get it wrong. Take Tiananmen Square. This week is the 10th anniversary of the crackdown and the massacre there. And you think you know the story. Idealistic students trying to democratize their government. But in fact, it was more complicated than that.
提到青少年，我们总是会误解。即使是在那些被最广泛审视、报道最多的故事中，我们也搞错了。以天安门广场为例。这周是那里发生镇压和屠杀事件的10周年。你以为你知道那个故事。理想主义的学生试图让他们的政府民主化。但实际上，情况比那要复杂得多。
The majority of students were like me. I was a very typical student at that time. And our knowledge of what democracy was was really limited.
大多数学生和我一样。我当时是一个非常典型的学生。我们对什么是民主的了解真的很有限。
Wen Huang was part of the student movement, first in Shanghai, where he was a graduate student at the time, then in Beijing at Tiananmen Square right up until the crackdown on June 4, 1989. And he says that for him and most of the students he knew, the movement was not about turning China into more of a democracy. He says students wanted the government to cutdown on corruption, do something about inflation, allow them to criticize the government without being thrown in jail or kept from good jobs.
文煌（Wen Huang）曾是学生运动的一员，最初是在上海，他当时是一名研究生，后来在北京天安门广场，直到1989年6月4日的镇压。他说，对他和他认识的大多数学生来说，这场运动并不是为了让中国变成一个更民主的国家。他说学生们希望政府打击腐败，解决通货膨胀问题，允许他们批评政府而不被关进监狱或被剥夺好工作。
It never occurred to us that we wanted to overthrow the Communist government. It was like the Communist party was a God-given thing. And we were born with it. We're going to die with it. And the only way to make it work for us is just to have some modest reforms within the government.
我们从未想过要推翻共产党政府。感觉共产党就像是天赐之物。我们与生俱来，也要与之共存。让它为我们所用的唯一方法，就是在政府内部进行一些温和的改革。
But Wen says that for most of the students he knew, most of the students in the movement, he believes, there was another motivation besides politics, an equally compelling, if not more compelling, motivation.
但文说，他认为在他认识的大多数学生、大多数参与运动的学生中，除了政治之外，还有另一种动机，一种同样令人信服，甚至更具说服力的动机。
It was really like a big party. I never heard about Woodstock until I came to the US.
那真的就像一场大型派对。在来美国之前，我从没听说过伍德斯托克（Woodstock）。
Woodstock, yeah.
伍德斯托克，是的。
Woodstock. And then later on, I watched a video tape. And then suddenly, I realized that the student movement in 1989 was just like a big-- similar to the Woodstock experience.
伍德斯托克。后来，我看了录像带。然后我突然意识到，1989年的学生运动就像一场大型的——类似于伍德斯托克的经历。
Why? What were you seeing that was similar in 1989 in China, in Tiananmen Square, and in Shanghai that was similar to what was going on at Woodstock?
为什么？你在1989年的中国，在天安门广场和上海，看到了什么类似于伍德斯托克发生的事情？
The festive atmosphere and the playfulness. And we were singing pop songs, and people playing guitars.
那种节日气氛和嬉闹感。我们唱着流行歌曲，人们弹着吉他。
It was exciting, Wen says. Midterms were coming up. Papers were due. And everybody would skip class together to go to demonstrations. This is not to say that there was not political idealism behind all this. There was. But as one of the best known student leaders, Chai Ling, said in an article in The New Yorker magazine commemorating the 10th anniversary of Tiananmen Square, the demonstrations, even the hunger strikes weren't primarily political as far as she was concerned. It was about a kind of sheer pleasure in living, she said, a rock and roll bravado. Wen Huang agrees.
文说，那很令人兴奋。期中考试要到了，论文要交了，大家都逃课一起去参加示威游行。这并不是说这一切背后没有政治理想主义。有的。但正如最著名的学生领袖之一柴玲在《纽约客》杂志纪念天安门事件10周年的一篇文章中所说，就她而言，示威游行，甚至绝食抗议，主要都不是政治性的。她说，这关乎一种纯粹的生存快乐，一种摇滚式的虚张声势。文煌表示赞同。
I think that was kind of accurate statement. I think there was more of an honest assessment of what's motivated us to take part in this movement. Because I noticed when I first came out here, the student leaders who escaped China--
我认为这是一种准确的说法。我认为这是对我们参与这场运动动机的更诚实的评估。因为我注意到当我刚出来时，那些逃离中国的学生领袖——
The student leaders who escaped, uh-huh.
那些逃出来的学生领袖，嗯。
The student leaders who escaped China, when they came over here, they exaggerated the motivation. They portrayed themselves as such democracy fighters, as if they knew so much about democracy. And that has a lot to do with how Americans have this romantic vision of the Tiananmen Square movement.
那些逃离中国的学生领袖，当他们来到这里时，他们夸大了这种动机。他们把自己描绘成民主斗士，好像他们对民主非常了解。这与美国人对天安门广场运动所持有的这种浪漫化想象有很大关系。
Of course, it goes further than this. We Americans have a romantic vision of what it means just to be a student, what it means to be young. And we ascribe a lot of motivations and meaning to what young people do that simply don't bear much relation to reality. Today on our program, we try to set the record straight with a few typical case examples. From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
当然，这还不止于此。我们美国人对“学生”意味着什么，对“年轻”意味着什么，有着一种浪漫化的想象。我们将许多动机和意义归结于年轻人的行为，而这些行为与现实并没有太大关系。今天在我们的节目中，我们试图通过几个典型的案例来澄清事实。来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台（PRI），这是《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。
Today's program, The Kids Are Alright, stories in which people try to set the record straight about actions that adults seem to widely misinterpret. Act One, Where The People Walk Around Upside Down. A story about what you think you know about the 1989 student uprising in China versus what really happened. Act Two, When Czechs Bounce. The true tale of how young people's music in Czechoslovakia in the 1940s and '50s seemed to pose a threat first to the Nazi occupation, then to communist authorities.
今天的节目，《孩子们没问题》（The Kids Are Alright），在这个故事中，人们试图纠正成年人似乎广泛误解的行为。第一幕，人们倒立行走的地方（Where The People Walk Around Upside Down）。一个关于你以为你了解的1989年中国学生起义与实际发生情况的故事。第二幕，当捷克人跳动时（When Czechs Bounce）。这是一个真实的传奇故事，讲述了20世纪40和50年代捷克斯洛伐克年轻人的音乐，最初似乎对纳粹占领构成了威胁，后来又对共产党当局构成了威胁。
Act Three, When We Were Animals. Someone who helped perpetrate high school violence when he was a teenager tries to find the blurry line that divides childhood prank from social pathology. Act Four, When We Were Angels, in which we hear the purest possible student uprising imaginable, the most innocent, documented by an actual student using the crude tools of telephone answering machine and shiny, red boom box. Stay with us.
第三幕，当我们是野兽时（When We Were Animals）。一个在青少年时期曾参与高中暴力事件的人，试图找到划分童年恶作剧与社会病态的模糊界限。第四幕，当我们是天使时（When We Were Angels），我们听到了可以想象到的最纯粹的学生起义，最天真的起义，由一名真正的学生使用电话答录机和闪亮的红色手提音响等原始工具记录下来。请留下来。
Act One, Where the People Walk Around Upside Down. Growing up in China, Wen Huang believed that China was an advanced country, a civilized country, which provided for all its citizens, not like those countries with poor people in them.
第一幕，人们倒立行走的地方。文煌在中国的成长过程中，相信中国是一个先进的国家，一个文明的国家，为所有公民提供保障，不像那些有穷人的国家。
I remember when I was growing up, each time I couldn't finish my meal, my mom always say, "Oh, you gotta finish your meal. Just imagine how lucky you are. People in America are starving." And of course, I heard the same thing.
我记得我小时候，每次吃不完饭，我妈妈总是说：“噢，你得把饭吃完。想象一下你有多幸运。美国的穷人都在挨饿。”当然，我也听过同样的话。
And of course, once you came to this country, everybody told you, "My mom would say to me, 'Yes, finish your meal because there are children starving in China.'"
当然，一旦你来到这个国家，每个人都告诉你：“我妈妈会对我这么说，‘是的，把饭吃完，因为中国有孩子在挨饿。’”
Yeah, I actually believed that. I remember that was our impression of America. We thought China was very strong. We felt very lucky to be under the socialist system.
是的，我当时真的相信。我记得那是我们对美国的印象。我们认为中国非常强大。我们感到非常幸运能生活在社会主义制度下。
In a more advanced system, where that wouldn't happen.
在一个更先进的制度下，那种事就不会发生。
In a more advanced system, everybody's equal. And then suddenly, in the 1980s, when China opened up to the outside world, we suddenly felt that we were left behind. And there was the phrase saying that we were at least 30 or 40 years behind the United States and England. And we felt humiliated in a way.
在一个更先进的制度下，人人平等。然后突然间，在20世纪80年代，当中国向外部世界开放时，我们突然感到我们被抛在了后面。当时有一句话说，我们至少落后美国和英国30或40年。我们在某种程度上感到羞辱。
Students like Wen had friends who'd gone overseas, who'd seen that in Europe and America, the grocery stores had 30 different kinds of cookies, that it was fantastic prosperity abroad. Meanwhile, opening to the West meant the end of wage and price controls back home in China, and prices were skyrocketing. Wen remembers living on $10 a month American and watching the price of tomatoes climb from $0.01 a pound to $0.30 a pound. It just didn't seem like there was any kind of future to be had in China, anything to be idealistic about. That was what sent students to the streets, Wen says, not some idea of American-style democracy, which they didn't know much about anyway.
像文这样的学生，有朋友去了海外，他们看到在欧洲和美国的杂货店里有30种不同的饼干，国外有着梦幻般的繁荣。与此同时，向西方开放意味着中国国内工资和价格管制的终结，物价正在飞涨。文记得当时每月靠10美元生活，看着西红柿的价格从每磅1美分涨到30美分。在中国似乎没有任何未来可言，没有任何值得理想主义追求的东西。文说，这就是驱使学生走上街头的原因，而不是什么美国式的民主理念，他们本来就对民主了解不多。
We really had a mentality of "We could save this world." We were young. There was a Chinese phrase, saying, "A newborn calf doesn't know the danger ahead." That is exactly what we were. We felt like the whole future-- we could change the future. We could change the country. As how we're going to change it, we didn't know.
我们真的有一种“我们可以拯救世界”的心态。我们很年轻。中国有句成语叫“初生牛犊不怕虎”。这正是我们当时的样子。我们觉得整个未来——我们可以改变未来。我们可以改变这个国家。至于如何改变，我们不知道。
So we grew up watching these movies about the martyrs, for example, during the early communist movements, how people would face the bullets to die for a cause. And that really had the impact. We felt like we wanted to be part of it. I remember during the Cultural Revolution, thousands of Red Guards-- like my uncle and my aunt, they were Red Guards-- thousand Red Guards, they traveled hundreds of miles to Beijing to see Chairman Mao Zedong, who was the leader of the communist movement. He was like a living god.
所以我们在成长过程中观看了那些关于烈士的电影，例如在早期的共产主义运动中，人们如何为了事业面对子弹去赴死。这确实产生了影响。我们觉得我们想成为其中的一部分。我记得在文化大革命期间，成千上万的红卫兵——就像我的叔叔和阿姨，他们是红卫兵——成千上万的红卫兵长途跋涉数百里来到北京，去见共产主义运动的领导人毛泽东主席。他就像一个活神仙。
And my aunt and my uncle told me that they were young, and they would walk hundreds of miles. And sometimes, when they took the train, the train was so crowded that people had to stand in the toilets for 7 or 8 hours or 20 hours. And also, people have to cram into the luggage rack just to go to Beijing to see Chairman Mao. And later on, during the 1980s, we found that was kind of stupid. The Red Guards, they really did a lot of damage.
我阿姨和叔叔告诉我，他们当时很年轻，他们会走上数百英里。有时，当他们坐火车时，火车太拥挤了，人们不得不站在厕所里7、8个小时甚至20个小时。人们还必须挤进行李架，只为了去北京见毛主席。后来，在20世纪80年代，我们发现那其实挺愚蠢的。红卫兵确实造成了很大的破坏。
But on the other part was the fantasy. I felt like, I wish I could live in that time to experience the excitement that my aunt and my uncle, they lived. Because each time they reminisced that, their voice started changing. They got excited. It's like part of the experience. I always felt like I wanted to be that part of experience.
但另一部分是幻想。我觉得，我真希望自己能生活在那个时代，去体验我阿姨和叔叔曾经拥有的那种兴奋感。因为每次他们回忆起那些，他们的声音就开始变了。他们变得很兴奋。那就像是体验的一部分。我一直觉得我想成为那种体验的一部分。
That was why, when I was in Shanghai after the students' hunger strike, I felt like I really wanted to go where the action was. So I took the train to Beijing. I remember very clearly that on the spur of the moment, I said, "I want to go to Beijing." And my classmates said, "Let's go." And we had a bag, only had a toothbrush and several books. We never had the idea, "We need to change." We said, "We want to be a revolutionary."
这就是为什么当我在学生绝食后在上海时，我觉得我真的想去那个行动的核心地带。所以我坐火车去了北京。我记得非常清楚，在那个冲动的瞬间，我说：“我想去北京。”我的同学说：“我们走吧。”我们带了一个包，里面只有一把牙刷和几本书。我们从来没有“我们需要改变”的想法。我们说：“我们要成为革命者。”
And when we went to the train station, it was so crowded, there was no way we could get a ticket with a seat. So we just bought a platform ticket, and we snuck in. And when we got on the train, it was very crowded. And then I thought about the experience of my aunt and my uncle. I kind of hoped that the train would be so crowded that I had to go stand in the toilets for 20 hours to go to Beijing.
当我们去火车站时，那里太拥挤了，我们根本买不到有座位的票。所以我们只买了月台票，偷偷混了进去。当我们上了火车，车厢非常拥挤。然后我想起了我阿姨和叔叔的经历。我甚至希望火车能挤到我必须在厕所里站20个小时才能到北京。
I just sat in the aisle, and I kept thinking, "Oh, this is not as exciting as my aunt and my uncle experienced." It's just the side of living the fantasy. And also, when I was in Beijing, when we heard the martial law, the troops were going to march in, my classmates and I, we were always wanting to talk, we said, "If the soldiers start shoot us, we'll walk hand-in-hand, and then just walk towards them, and then we may die as martyrs." The fantasies we got from watching the movies is so heroic.
我只是坐在过道里，一直想：“哦，这没有我阿姨和叔叔经历的那么刺激。”这只是生活在幻想中的一面。而且，当我在北京时，当我们听到戒严令，军队要开进来时，我的同学和我，我们总是想说话，我们说：“如果士兵开始射击我们，我们就手拉手，然后就这样走向他们，也许我们可以作为烈士死去。”从电影中得到的幻想是如此英雄主义。
Now, looking back, I thought I was very stupid. But then I still think it was a very important part of my life. I'm glad I did it.
现在回想起来，我觉得当时我很愚蠢。但即便如此，我仍然认为这是我生命中非常重要的一部分。我很高兴我做了这件事。
One of the actions that led up to the events in Tiananmen Square were the hunger strikes that took place in different cities, students in different cities, including in Shanghai. And that seems like a situation where students actually were putting themselves on the line and would starve themselves for days.
导致天安门广场事件的行动之一是发生在不同城市的绝食抗议，包括上海的学生。那看起来是一个学生真正把自己置于危险之中，并且会绝食数天的情形。
Yes, I can say that when my best friend, we grew up in the same city, and he said, he was going to be on hunger strike. I said, "What is hunger strike? How are you going to do it?" He said, "Oh, you're just going to starve yourself."
是的，我可以这样说，当我的好朋友——我们是在同一个城市长大的——他说他要参加绝食时。我说：“什么是绝食？你打算怎么做？”他说：“噢，你就是饿着自己。”
And I was really touched since I went with him, I saw students, they had a massive sit-in in the square. And then those who were on hunger strike, they were in a special place. They were really serious. And the next day, I decide to help my friend.
我真的很受触动，我和他一起去了，我看到学生们在广场上进行大规模静坐。那些绝食的人在特定的地方。他们真的很严肃。第二天，我决定去帮助我的朋友。
So I brought some water, bottled water, and a quilt. And I went to the square to look for him. So I went over there. I couldn't find him anywhere. And also, I noticed that there were a  lot of new faces. The students who were there the previous night were no longer there, a lot of them.
所以我带了一些水、瓶装水和一床被子。我去广场找他。我去到那里，到处都找不到他。而且，我注意到有很多新面孔。前一天晚上在那里的学生已经不在了，很多人都不在了。
So I just went back to the school. And I was in the students' cafeteria. I found that he was eating a big bowl of noodle. I said, "Aren't you supposed to be on hunger strike?" He said, "Oh, after the first 12 hours, I was so hungry, I just couldn't stand it. And that's why. It was too much for me. I decided to come back." He said, "We're human."
所以我回到了学校。我在学生食堂里发现他正在吃一大碗面条。我说：“你不是应该在绝食吗？”他说：“噢，前12小时过后，我太饿了，我实在受不了。这就是原因。对我来说这太困难了。我决定回来。”他说：“我们是凡人。”
You're not saying that no one was sincere and that no one was striking.
你并不是说没有人是真诚的，也没有人在绝食。
No, I'm sure there were a lot of people who were very sincere about that.
不，我相信有很多人的确是非常真诚的。
And actually did starve themselves.
而且确实饿着自己。
They did starve-- a hunger strike. But a lot of people-- I come back to the point that because it was a big party and, also, it was such a big show, a lot of people join us. And we were young kids. They just started to go on hunger strike for the show. And then when nobody was looking, they go and eat something.
他们确实饿了——参加了绝食。但很多人——我回到那个观点，因为那是一场大型派对，也是一场巨大的表演，很多人加入我们。我们是年轻的孩子。他们刚开始绝食是为了表现。当没人注意时，他们就去吃东西了。
Wen, do you think that when the Western press has tended to write about Tiananmen Square and the student movement that they've been more pious about it than it felt to be in that movement?
文，你认为当西方媒体倾向于撰写有关天安门广场和学生运动的文章时，他们是否比身处其中的人表现得更虔诚？
I think that my general impression of the Western media, their coverage of Tiananmen Square is they tend to romanticize the movement. When I came over here, the first things, people started to call me "democracy fighter." I always cringe at that idea when people start to-- of course, I like the treatment.
我对西方媒体的总体印象是，他们对天安门的报道往往会将这场运动浪漫化。当我来到这里，第一件事就是人们开始称我为“民主斗士”。当人们开始这样称呼我时，我总是感到尴尬——当然，我喜欢这种礼遇。
I remember one day I was invited to talk about Tiananmen Square. That's the first year I was in Springfield, Illinois. I went to talk to a civic group about Tiananmen Square and human rights in China. And I had some pictures of me marching in Tiananmen Square.
我记得有一天我被邀请去谈论天安门广场。那是我在伊利诺伊州斯普林菲尔德的第一年。我去向一个公民团体谈论天安门广场和中国的民主。我带了一些我在天安门广场游行的照片。
So try to impress audience, I show them some pictures. And then the organizer of the speech immediately started to refer to me as "a democracy fighter." And then they all stood up and clapped hands. I felt like I was a hero. I kind of liked the treatment.
为了给观众留下深刻印象，我向他们展示了一些照片。演讲的主办方立刻开始称我为“民主斗士”。然后他们都站起来鼓掌。我感觉自己成了英雄。我挺喜欢这种礼遇。
But then also, I felt obligated to tell them that I really didn't know anything about democracy at that time. So I just said, "I wasn't really a democracy fighter. I had no idea what democracy was." And they were little disappointed.
但也因此，我觉得有义务告诉他们，我当时真的对民主一无所知。所以我说：“我并不是真的民主斗士。我根本不知道什么是民主。”他们感到有些失望。
Wen Huang is a freelance journalist here in Chicago.
文煌是芝加哥的一名自由记者。
Act Two, When Czechs Bounce. If part of the impulse behind the Tiananmen Square uprising was the pure desire to feel like life had possibility, that the future had potential, that was the same impulse behind another movement among young people in Eastern Europe, back before the Berlin Wall fell. That movement was not, strictly speaking, political, though it took on a political dimension. It had to do with music. Josef Skvorecky wrote an essay about jazz in Czechoslovakia as a preface to his novella, The Bass Saxophone. That was also before the Berlin wall fell. We asked actor Ed Dixon to read an except for us here.
第二幕，当捷克人跳动时。如果天安门广场起义背后的部分动力是那种纯粹的想要感觉到生命有可能性、未来有潜力的渴望，那么在柏林墙倒塌之前，东欧年轻人的另一场运动背后也有同样的动力。严格来说，那场运动并不是政治性的，尽管它带有了政治维度。它与音乐有关。约瑟夫·什克沃莱茨基（Josef Skvorecky）在柏林墙倒塌前为他的中篇小说《低音萨克斯风》（The Bass Saxophone）撰写了一篇关于捷克斯洛伐克爵士乐的序文。我们请演员埃德·迪克森（Ed Dixon）为我们朗读其中的节选。
In the days when everything in life was fresh because we were 16, 17, I used to blow tenor sax very poorly. Our band was called Red Music, which, in fact, was a misnomer since the name had no political connotations. There was a band in Prague that called itself Blue Music. And we, living in the Nazi protectorate of Bohemia and Moravia, had no idea that, in jazz, "blue" was not a color. So we called ours "red."
在那个生命中一切都充满新鲜感的日子里，因为那时我们只有16、17岁，我曾经吹得非常糟糕的次中音萨克斯。我们的乐队叫“红色音乐”（Red Music），事实上这个名字用错了，因为这个名字没有任何政治含义。布拉格有一个乐队自称“蓝色音乐”（Blue Music）。我们生活在波希米亚和摩拉维亚的纳粹保护国里，不知道在爵士乐中，“蓝色”并不是一种颜色。所以我们把我们的乐队叫作“红色”。
But if the name itself had no political connotations, our sweet, wild music did. For jazz was a sharp thorn in the sides of the power-hungry men, from Hitler to Brezhnev, who successively ruled in my native land. What sort of political connotations? Leftist? Rightist? Racialist? Classist? Nationalist?
但如果名字本身没有政治含义，我们那甜美、狂野的音乐却有。因为对于从希特勒到勃列日涅夫这些相继统治我故土的权力狂人来说，爵士乐是一根扎在他们侧面的尖锐刺。什么政治含义？左翼的？右翼的？种族主义的？阶级主义的？民族主义的？
The vocabulary of ideologists and mountebanks doesn't have a word for it. The essence of this music, this way of making music, is not simply protest. Its essence is something far more elemental, an elan vital, a forceful vitality, an explosive creative energy as breathtaking as that of any true art that may be felt even in the saddest of blues. Its effect is cathartic.
意识形态专家和江湖骗子的词汇库里没有词来形容它。这种音乐的本质，这种创作音乐的方式，不仅仅是抗议。它的本质是更原始的东西，一种“生命力”（elan vital），一种强劲的生命力，一种像任何真正的艺术一样令人惊叹的爆炸性创造能量，即使在最悲伤的蓝调中也能感受到。它的效果是宣泄性的。
But of course, when the lives of individuals and communities are controlled by powers that themselves remain uncontrolled, slavers, czars, fuehrers, first secretaries, marshals, generals, and generalissimos, ideologists of dictatorships at either end of the spectrum, then creative energy becomes a protest. That is the way it is. Totalitarian ideologists don't like real life, other people's, because it cannot be totally controlled. They loathe art, the product of a yearning for life, because that, too, evades control. If controlled and legislated, it perishes.
当然，当个人和社区的生活被那些自身不受控制的权力——奴隶主、沙皇、元首、第一书记、元帅、将军、大元帅、处于两个极端意识形态的独裁者——所控制时，创造性能量就会变成抗议。事实就是如此。极权主义的意识形态专家不喜欢真实的生活，不喜欢别人的生活，因为它无法被完全控制。他们憎恶艺术，这种对生活渴望的产物，因为它也逃避控制。如果被控制和立法，它就会灭亡。
But before it perishes, or when it finds refuge in some kind of samizdat underground, art, willy-nilly, becomes protest. Popular mass art, like jazz, becomes mass protest. That's why the ideological guns, and sometimes even the police guns, of all dictatorships are aimed at the men with the horns.
但在它灭亡之前，或者当它在某种地下出版物（samizdat）中找到避难所时，艺术，无论如何，都会变成抗议。像爵士乐这样的大众艺术，变成了大众抗议。这就是为什么所有独裁政权的意识形态枪支，有时甚至包括警察的枪支，都瞄准了那些拿着号角的乐手们。
Red Music used to play, badly, but with the enthusiasm of 16-year-olds during the reign of the most Aryan Aryan of them all and his cultural handyman, Doctor Goebbels. It was Goebbels who declared, "Now I shall speak quite openly on the question of whether German radio should broadcast so-called jazz music. If by jazz, we mean music that is based on rhythm and entirely ignores or even shows contempt for melody, music in which rhythm is indicated primarily by the ugly sounds of whining instruments so insulting to the soul, why, then we can only reply to the question entirely in the negative." Which was the reason we whined and wailed, rasped and roared, using all kinds of wah-wah and hat mutes, some of them manufactured by ourselves.
在那个最纯正的雅利安人及其文化杂工戈培尔博士统治期间，我们的“红色音乐”乐队曾经演奏得很烂，但充满了16岁孩子的热情。正是戈培尔宣称：“现在我就关于德国广播电台是否应该播放所谓爵士乐的问题公开表态。如果爵士乐是指基于节奏、完全忽视甚至表现出对旋律蔑视的音乐，如果在这种音乐中，节奏主要是通过那些侮辱灵魂的刺耳乐器的丑陋声音来表现的，那么我们只能完全否定这一问题。”这就是为什么我们呜呜作响、尖声惊叫、发出刮擦和咆哮声，使用了各种各样的哇音器（wah-wah）和帽子弱音器，其中一些还是我们自己制造的。
But even then, protest was one of the lesser reasons. Primarily, we loved that music we called jazz and that, in fact, was swing, the half-white progeny of Chicago and New Orleans that our non-blowing contemporaries danced to in mountain villages out of reach of the Schutzpolizei, the uniformed security service. For even dancing was forbidden in the Third Reich, which was in mourning for the dead of the Battle of Stalingrad.
但即使在当时，抗议也只是其中较小的原因。最主要的是，我们热爱那种我们称之为爵士乐的音乐，实际上那是摇摆乐（swing），是芝加哥和新奥尔良那种半白人的后代，我们那些不吹奏乐器的同龄人在“舒茨警察”（Schutzpolizei，即统一的安全服务）够不着的山村里跳着这种舞。因为即使在为斯大林格勒战役的死者哀悼的第三帝国，跳舞也是被禁止的。
The revelation we experienced was one of those that can only come in one's youth, before the soul has acquired a shell from being touched by too many sensations. In my mind, I can still hear very clearly the sound of the saxes on that old, terribly scratchy Brunswick 78, spinning on a wind-up phonograph with the almost illegible label, "I've Got A Guy, Chick Webb And His Orchestra With Vocal Chorus." Wildly sweet, soaring, swinging saxophones. The lazy and unknown voice of the unknown vocalist who left us spellbound, even though we had no way of knowing that this was the great, then 17-year-old Ella Fitzgerald. But the message of her voice, the call of the saxes, the short wailing, weeping saxophone solo between the two vocal choruses, they all came across. Nothing could ever silence them in our hearts.
我们经历的那种启示，是只能在青春时期获得的，在灵魂因接触过多的感官而长出外壳之前。在我的脑海中，我依然能清晰地听到萨克斯在旧的、极其刺耳的布伦瑞克78转唱片上的声音，在那台几乎看不清标签的旧留声机上旋转，“我有一个家伙，奇克·韦布和他的管弦乐队伴唱”（I've Got A Guy, Chick Webb And His Orchestra With Vocal Chorus）。狂野甜美、高亢、摇摆的萨克斯。那位不知名歌手慵懒而未知的嗓音，让我们着迷，尽管我们无法知道这就是后来伟大的、当时年仅17岁的艾拉·菲茨杰拉德（Ella Fitzgerald）。但她歌声传递的信息，萨克斯的呼唤，那两段合唱之间简短的哀鸣、哭泣般的萨克斯独奏，它们都传达了出来。没有什么能让它们在我们心中沉默。
There was even a swing band in the notorious Buchenwald, made up, for the most part, of Czech and French prisoners. And since those were not only cruel, but also absurd times, people were put behind barbed wire because of the very music that was played inside. In a concentration camp near Wiener Neustadt, sat Vicherek, a guitar player who had sung Louis Armstrong's scat chorus in "Tiger Rag" and thus, according to the Nazi judge, defiled musical culture. Elsewhere in Germany, several swing men met a similar fate.
在臭名昭著的布痕瓦尔德集中营里，甚至有一个摇摆乐队，主要是由捷克和法国囚犯组成的。由于那是一个既残酷又荒谬的时代，人们因为在营地里演奏的音乐而被关进铁丝网后面。在维也纳新城附近的一个集中营里，坐着维切雷克（Vicherek），一名吉他手，他因为唱了路易斯·阿姆斯特朗（Louis Armstrong）在《老虎瑞格》（Tiger Rag）中的拟声吟唱，从而被纳粹法官认为玷污了音乐文化。在德国的其他地方，几名摇摆乐手也遭遇了同样的命运。
And one local Gauleiter issued an extraordinary-- really extraordinary in this world of ours-- set of regulations which were binding for all dance orchestras. I read them, gnashing my teeth, in Czech translation in the film weekly, Filmovy kuryr. And 15 years later, I paraphrase them, faithfully, I'm sure, since they had engraved themselves deeply on my mind, in a short story entitled "I Won't Take Back One Word."
当地的一位大区长官发布了一套非同寻常——在这个世界上确实非同寻常——的规定，这些规定对所有的舞厅乐团具有约束力。我咬牙切齿地在电影周报《Filmovy kuryr》上读到了捷克语翻译的版本。15年后，我确信自己忠实地转述了它们，因为它们深刻地铭刻在我的脑海中，收录在名为《我不收回一个字》（I Won't Take Back One Word）的短篇小说里。
One, pieces in foxtrot rhythms, so-called swing, are not to exceed 20% of the repertoires of light orchestras and dance bands. Two, in this so-called jazz-type repertoire, preference is to be given to compositions in a major key and to lyrics expressing joy and life, rather than Jewishly gloomy lyrics. Three, as to tempo, preference is also to be given to brisk compositions over slow ones, so-called blues. However, the pace must not exceed a certain degree of allegro commensurate with the Aryan sense of discipline and moderation. On no account will Negroid excesses in tempo, so-called hot jazz, or in solo performances, so-called breaks, be tolerated.
一，狐步舞节奏的曲目，所谓的摇摆乐，不得超过轻音乐团和舞厅乐队曲目的20%。二，在这种所谓的爵士风格曲目中，优先考虑大调的作品和表达欢乐与生活的歌词，而不是犹太式的阴郁歌词。三，至于节奏，优先考虑轻快的作品，而不是缓慢的作品，即所谓的蓝调。然而，速度不得超过与雅利安人的纪律和节制感相符的某种快板程度。绝不允许在速度（所谓的“热爵士”）或独奏表演（所谓的“断奏”或“break”）中出现尼格罗式的过度放纵。
Four, strictly prohibited is the use of instruments alien to the German spirit, so-called cowbells, flexatones, brushes, et cetera, as well as all mutes, which turn the noble sound of wind and brass instruments into a Jewish-Free-Masonic yowl, so-called wah-wahs, hats, et cetera. Five, all light orchestra and dance bands are advised to restrict the use of saxophones of all keys and to substitute for them the violincello, the viola, or possibly a suitable folk instrument.
四，严格禁止使用背离德国精神的乐器，所谓的牛铃、弯音琴、刷子等，以及所有的弱音器，那些将管乐和铜管乐器的崇高声音变成犹太-自由工匠式的嚎叫的东西，所谓的哇音器、帽子弱音器等。五，建议所有轻音乐团和舞厅乐队限制在所有调式中使用萨克斯风，并用大提琴、中提琴或合适的民间乐器替代它们。
How naive we were, how full of love and reverence because Doctor Goebbels had decided that the whining Judeo-Negroid music invented by American capitalists was not to be played in the territory of the Third Reich. We had a ball inventing aliases for legendary tunes, so that they might be heard in the territory of the Third Reich after all. We played a fast piece, one of those forbidden "brisk" compositions, called "The Wild Bull," indistinguishable to the naked ear from "Tiger Rag." We played a low tune, "Abendlied" or "Evening Song."
我们多么天真，多么充满爱与敬意，因为戈培尔博士已经裁定，这种由美国资本家发明的、令人厌恶的犹太-尼格罗式音乐不得在第三帝国的领土上播放。我们在发明传说曲目的别名方面玩得很开心，这样它们最终还是能在第三帝国的领土上被听到。我们演奏了一首快曲，那些被禁的“轻快”作品之一，叫作“野牛”（The Wild Bull），普通耳朵听起来和“老虎瑞格”没什么区别。我们演奏了一首慢曲，“晚间之歌”（Abendlied）。
And fortunately, the Nazi censors had never heard the black voice singing, "When the deep purple falls over sleepy garden walls." And the height of our effrontery, "The Song of Resetova Lhota," in fact "Saint Louis Blues," rang out one misty day in 1943 in eastern Bohemia, sung in Czech by a country girl, the lyrics composed so that they might elaborate on our new title for W. C. Handy's theme song, "Resetova Lhota is where I go. I'm on my way to see my Aryan folk."
幸运的是，纳粹审查员从未听过那个黑人歌手唱：“当深紫色笼罩在慵懒的庭院墙壁上。”我们厚颜无耻的巅峰之作，“雷塞托瓦洛塔之歌”（The Song of Resetova Lhota），实际上是“圣路易斯蓝调”（Saint Louis Blues），在1943年波希米亚东部的一个雾天里响起，由一名乡村女孩用捷克语演唱，歌词是为了配合我们为W.C.汉迪（W.C. Handy）的主题曲起的新名字：“雷塞托瓦洛塔是我去的地方。我在去看我的雅利安同胞的路上。”
In fact, we were fortunate that the local Nazis had never seen Chaplin's The Great Dictator, never heard the bullies sing about, "the Ary-- Ary-- Ary-- Ary-- Aryans." Neither had we of course. The song of "Resetova Lhota" was simply an indigenous response to Nazism. Count Basie, Louis Armstrong, Tommy Dorsey, Benny Goodman, Glenn Miller. You name them, we knew them all. And yet, we knew nothing.
实际上，我们很幸运，当地的纳粹分子从未看过卓别林的《大独裁者》，也从未听过恶霸们唱着“雅——雅——雅——雅——雅利安人”。当然，我们也没有听过。“雷塞托瓦洛塔之歌”只是对纳粹主义的一种本土回应。考特·贝西（Count Basie）、路易斯·阿姆斯特朗（Louis Armstrong）、汤米·多尔西（Tommy Dorsey）、本尼·古德曼（Benny Goodman）、格伦·米勒（Glenn Miller）。只要你能叫出名字的，我们全都知道。然而，我们又一无所知。
The hours we spent racking our brains over song titles we couldn't understand. "Struttin' with some barbecue." The definition of the word "barbecue" in our pocket Webster didn't help at all. What on earth could it mean? Walking pompously with a piece of animal carcass roasted whole?
我们绞尽脑汁试图理解那些歌名，但失败了。“Struttin' with some barbecue”（伴着烧烤昂首阔步）。我们袖珍韦氏词典里对“烧烤”这个词的定义毫无帮助。它到底能意味着什么？难道是带着一块整只烤过的动物尸体在 pompously 地走来走去？
We knew nothing. But we knew the music. It came to us on the waves of Radio Stockholm mostly since that was the only station that played jazz that the Nazis didn't jam. Far from Harlem, from Chicago, from New Orleans, uninformed and naive, we served the sacrament that verily knows no frontiers.
我们一无所知。但我们懂得音乐。它主要通过瑞典电台的电波传给我们，因为那是唯一一家播放爵士乐且纳粹没有干扰的电台。远离哈莱姆，远离芝加哥，远离新奥尔良，在无知和天真中，我们侍奉着真正不分国界的圣餐。
Then The Great War ended. I had the splendid feeling that finally, the beautiful age of jazz had arrived. My mistake. It took only a lean three years before it was back underground again. New little Goebbelses started working diligently in fields that had been cleared by the old demon. They had their own Soviet bibles, primarily the fascistoid Music of Spiritual Poverty by V. Gorodinsky and I. Nestyev's Dollar Cacophony.
然后大战结束了。我有一种灿烂的感觉，爵士乐的美好时代终于到来了。我错了。仅仅过了短短三年，它就又回到了地下。新的小戈培尔们开始勤奋地在老魔鬼清除过的领域里工作。他们有自己的苏联圣经，主要是法西斯式的《精神贫困的音乐》（Music of Spiritual Poverty，作者V. 戈罗丁斯基）和伊·涅斯捷耶夫的《美元的嘈杂声》（Dollar Cacophony）。
Their vocabulary was not very different from that of the little doctor except that they were, if possible, even prouder of their ignorance. They characterized jazz and jazz-inspired music by a rich assortment of derogatory adjectives, perverted, decadent, base, lying, degenerate, et cetera. They compared the music to "the moaning in the throat of a camel" and "the hiccupping of a drunk." And although it was "the music of cannibals," it was at the same time invented by the capitalists "to deafen the ears of the Marshallized world by means of epileptic loud-mouthed compositions."
他们的词汇与那位小博士的词汇没有什么不同，只是他们如果可能的话，对自己的无知感到更加骄傲。他们用各种各样的贬义词来描述爵士乐和受爵士乐启发的音乐：变态、颓废、卑劣、撒谎、堕落等等。他们将这种音乐比作“骆驼喉咙里的呻吟”和“醉汉的打嗝”。尽管它是“食人族的音乐”，但它同时又是资本家发明的，“通过癫痫般的吵闹作品让受马歇尔计划影响的世界震聋”。
Unfortunately, these Orwellian masters soon found their disciples among Czechs, who, in turn, after the fashion of disciples, went even further than their preceptors, declaring wildly that jazz was aimed at "annihilating the people's own music in their souls." Finally, the aggressive theoreticians even organized a concert of model jazz pieces composed to order for the party's cultural division. It was an incredible nightmare.
不幸的是，这些奥威尔式的统治者很快在捷克人中找到了门徒，这些门徒又按照门徒的方式，走得比他们的导师更远，疯狂地宣称爵士乐旨在“在人们的灵魂中消灭他们自己的音乐”。最终，那些激进的理论家甚至组织了一场应党文化部门要求创作的模范爵士乐音乐会。那是一场令人难以置信的噩梦。
Bandleader Karel Vlach, the greatest among Czech pioneers of swing, sat in the front row, going from crimson to ashen and from ashen to crimson again, probably saying a prayer in his soul to Stan Kenton. Beside him sat an unholy trinity of Soviet advisers on jazz led by, of all men, Aram Khachaturian, colleague of Prokofiev and Shostakovich, gloomy and silent. And next to them, a senile choir master using a hearing aid.
捷克摇摆乐先驱中最伟大的乐队领队卡雷尔·弗拉赫（Karel Vlach），坐在第一排，脸色从深红变到苍白，又从苍白变回深红，大概是在灵魂深处向斯坦·肯顿（Stan Kenton）祈祷。坐在他旁边的是三位苏联爵士乐顾问组成的非正统三位一体，带头的人竟然是亚兰·哈恰图良（Aram Khachaturian），他是普罗科菲耶夫和肖斯塔科维奇的同事，阴沉而沉默。在他们旁边，坐着一位使用助听器的老年唱诗班指挥。
And yet, not even the emasculated musical monster presented to them satisfied the Soviet advisers. They criticized its "instrumental makeup" and described it as "the music of a vanishing class." Finally, the old choir master rose. We heard him add the final chord. "Now take the trumpet. Such an optimistic-sounding instrument. And what do these jazz people do? They stuff something down its throat and right where it sounds despicable, whining like a jungle cry."
然而，即使是呈现给他们的那只被阉割过的音乐怪物，也没有满足苏联顾问。他们批评了它的“乐器构成”，并将其描述为“一个消失阶级的音乐”。最后，那位老唱诗班指挥站了起来。我们听到他弹出了最后的和弦：“现在拿这把小号来说。这是一种听起来多乐观的乐器。而这些爵士乐的人做了什么？他们往它喉咙里塞了些东西，正好在它听起来卑鄙的地方，像丛林中的叫声一样呜咽。”
After that, Vlach was unable to refrain from a few heretical remarks. If they didn't give him something better than Stan Kenton, said he, he would keep on playing Stan Kenton, which is perhaps what he did in the traveling circus to which he was shortly thereafter relegated along with his entire band.
在那之后，弗拉赫忍不住发表了几句异端言论。他说，如果他们不能提供比斯坦·肯顿更好的东西，他就会继续演奏斯坦·肯顿。这或许就是他后来被降职到巡回马戏团时所做的事情。
In place of Kenton, they pushed Paul Robeson at us. And how we hated that black apostle who sang of his own free will at open-air concerts in Prague at a time when they were raising the socialist leader, Milada Horakova, to the gallows, the only woman ever to be executed for political reasons in Czechoslovakia by Czechs, and at a time when the great Czech poets, some 10 years later to be rehabilitated without exception, were pining away in jails.
他们用保罗·罗伯逊（Paul Robeson）取代了肯顿。我们多么憎恨这位黑人使徒，他在布拉格的露天音乐会上自愿演唱，而当时他们正把社会主义领袖米拉达·霍拉科娃（Milada Horakova）送上绞刑架——她是捷克斯洛伐克历史上唯一因政治原因被捷克人处决的女性——而在同一时间，伟大的捷克诗人们，在约10年后都被无条件平反，当时却正在监狱里憔悴不堪。
Well, maybe it was wrong to hold it against Paul Robeson. No doubt, he was acting in good faith, convinced that he was fighting for a good cause. But they kept holding him up to us as an exemplary progressive jazz man, and we hated him. May God rest his hopefully-innocent soul.
好吧，也许把这件事怪在保罗·罗伯逊头上是不对的。毫无疑问，他是出于善意，坚信自己在为正义事业而战。但他们一直把他当作进步爵士乐手的典范推给我们，我们憎恨他。愿上帝保佑他那希望是天真的灵魂安息。
The steel chariots of the Soviets swung low, and I left. Jazz still leads a precarious existence in the heart of European political insanity, although the battlefield has shifted elsewhere. But it is the same old familiar story. A spectre is again haunting Eastern Europe, the spectre of rock. And all the reactionary powers have entered into an unholy alliance to exorcise it. Brezhnev and Husak, Suslov and Honecker, East German obscurantists and Czech police spies. Anonymous people hold underground Woodstocks in the same old obscure towns, gatherings often ruthlessly broken up by police, followed by the arrest of participants, their interrogation, their harassment, all the joys of living in a police state.
苏联的钢铁战车低空掠过，我离开了。爵士乐在欧洲政治疯狂的中心依然过着不稳定的生活，尽管战场已经转移到别处。但这依然是那个老掉牙的故事。幽灵再次在东欧游荡，那是摇滚乐的幽灵。所有反动势力都结成了邪恶的联盟来驱逐它。勃列日涅夫和胡萨克、苏斯洛夫和昂纳克、东德的蒙昧主义者和捷克的秘密警察。无名之辈在同样古老而模糊的城镇里举行地下的伍德斯托克音乐节，集会往往被警察无情地驱散，随后是参与者的被捕、审讯、骚扰，这一切都是在警察国家生活的乐趣。
My story has drawn to a close. Das Spiel ist ganz und gar verloren. Und dennoch wird es weitergehen. The game is totally lost. And yet, it will go on. The old music is dying. Although it has so many offspring, vigorous and vital, that will naturally be hated.
我的故事接近尾声了。“Das Spiel ist ganz und gar verloren. Und dennoch wird es weitergehen.” 游戏彻底输了。然而，它还会继续。旧的音乐正在消亡。尽管它有如此多的后代，充满活力和生命力，当然会遭到憎恨。
Still, for me, Duke is gone. Satchmo gone. Count Basie has just barely survived a heart attack. Little Jimmy Rushing has gone the way of all flesh. "Anybody asks you, who it was sang this song, just tell them it was-- he's been here and gone." Such is the epitaph of the little five-by-five. Such is the epitaph I would wish for my books.
不过，对我来说，公爵（Duke Ellington）走了。萨奇莫（Louis Armstrong）走了。考特·贝西（Count Basie）刚刚勉强熬过心脏病发作。小吉米·拉辛（Little Jimmy Rushing）走了所有肉身必经之路。“如果有人问你，是谁唱了这首歌，就告诉他们——他来过，然后又走了。”这就是那位五尺五寸歌手的墓志铭。这也是我希望为我的书写下的墓志铭。
An excerpt from Josef Skvorecky's essay "Red Music," which is collected in his book of essays titled Talkin' Moscow Blues. It was read for us by the magnificent Ed Dixon, an actor in New York City. He's now appearing on Broadway in The Iceman Cometh. Coming up, the most innocent childhood pranks in the world, and the least innocent, and why some people have a hard time telling one from the other. That's in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
以上节选自约瑟夫·什克沃莱茨基的散文《红色音乐》，该文收录在他题为《谈论莫斯科蓝调》（Talkin' Moscow Blues）的散文集中。由纽约市伟大的演员埃德·迪克森为我们朗读。他目前正在百老汇出演《送冰人来访》（The Iceman Cometh）。接下来的节目，世界上最天真的童年恶作剧，以及最不天真的恶作剧，以及为什么有些人很难区分两者。从PRI国际公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, The Kids Are Alright. Stories about teenagers who take things into their own hands and what to make of them, which we bring you today in the 10th anniversary of the Tiananmen Square crackdown. We've arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, When We Were Animals.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们选择一个主题，为你带来各种各样的相关故事。今天的节目，《孩子们没问题》。故事是关于青少年如何将事情掌控在自己手中，以及如何对待这些行为，我们在天安门广场镇压事件10周年之际为你带来这些内容。我们现在进入节目的第三幕。第三幕，当我们是野兽时。
Now we turn to a different kind of student action. The high school shootings in Littleton, Colorado have sent parents and teachers looking for warning signs that the children in their lives might suddenly strike out in some way. But the dividing line between normal childhood anger, normal childhood aggression, on the one hand, and social pathology, on the other, is usually not too easy to spot. Paul Bravmann tells this story from his boyhood in a suburban neighborhood on the West Coast about the sheer human difficulty of spotting that line.
现在我们转向另一种学生行动。科罗拉多州利特尔顿的高中枪击事件使家长和老师寻找孩子们可能突然以某种方式爆发的预警信号。但是，一方面是正常的童年愤怒、正常的童年攻击性，另一方面是社会病态，这两者之间的界限通常并不容易发现。保罗·布拉夫曼（Paul Bravmann）讲述了这个发生在他西海岸郊区童年时代的故事，关于识别那条界限所带来的纯粹的人性困难。
There were six of us. Most nights, we sat around the living room at Gus and Jack's house eating Nutter Butters and watching movies on the Betamax. But there were other nights when we just had to get out and goof around. It started innocently enough, Huck Finn and Tom Sawyer type of stuff. Like we'd go swimming on my neighbor's strip of private beach. Or we'd play these wild games of tag in the local graveyard.
我们有六个人。大多数晚上，我们坐在格斯（Gus）和杰克（Jack）家的客厅里吃花生酱三明治饼干，看Betamax录像带。但也有其他夜晚，我们不得不出去瞎混。事情开始得很单纯，像哈克·费恩和汤姆·索亚那一类的事。比如我们会去邻居的私人海滩游泳。或者我们在当地的墓地玩疯狂的捉迷藏。
There was our own small version of train hopping. We'd jump these slow-moving freight trains that carried apples, and car parts, and these fat tanks of chlorine gas through town, just ride them up and down the waterfront. Forms of play that bent the rules a bit. That's what made it exciting. That's what made us feel like our boyhood was the real deal.
我们有自己小版本的“跳火车”。我们会跳上那些缓慢行驶的货运火车，它们载着苹果、汽车零件和那种肥大的氯气罐穿过城镇，只是在海滨上下骑行。这些游戏打破了一点点规则。这正是让它令人兴奋的地方。这正是让我们觉得我们的童年是真实的感觉。
But then the nature of our play began to change. I'm not sure why exactly. So I've been going back, trying to piece together the history of those years. I contacted four of my former friends, Jack, Philip, Gordon, and Chris. Called them up out of the blue after 15 years. Here are Philip and Jack.
但随后我们游戏的性质开始改变。我不确定具体原因。所以我一直在回溯，试图拼凑出那几年的历史。我联系了我的四个前朋友，杰克、菲利普（Philip）、戈登（Gordon）和克里斯（Chris）。15年后突然给他们打了电话。这里是菲利普和杰克。
I remember once we took a garden hose and fed it through the window of a neighbor's car, a neighbor that we found somehow unsavory, and turned on the garden hose, and let 'er go. So come morning time, she had a small aquarium instead of a car.
我记得有一次我们拿了一根花园软管，把它伸进一个邻居的车窗里——那个邻居我们觉得有点令人讨厌——然后打开花园软管，让水流进去。所以第二天早上，她有了一个小型水族馆，而不是一辆车。
I remember one really disgusting prank is we all urinated into a five-gallon bucket for about a week until we had rancid stew of urine. It was so foul, you couldn't even go near it. But we somehow managed to put it in the back of a truck. And we drove around the island, looking for something or someone to dump it on. And we ended up finding some hapless person who was walking along the road in the middle of the night, fool that he was, and spilled this thing out the back onto him. That poor guy, going home reeking of piss.
我记得一个非常恶心的恶作剧，我们所有人都往一个5加仑的桶里尿尿，持续了大约一个星期，直到我们有了一桶腐臭的尿液炖物。那太臭了，你甚至不能靠近它。但我们还是设法把它放进了卡车的后备箱。我们开着车绕着岛转，寻找可以倒的对象。结果我们在深夜里找到了一个在路上走的可怜人，他真是个傻瓜，我们就把这东西从后面倒在他身上。那个可怜的家伙，回家时浑身散发着尿骚味。
Around this time, we were also getting really into pyrotechnics. We graduated from fireworks to Molotov cocktails, homemade napalm, and pipe bombs. We had gotten our hands on a pair of CIA explosives manuals and just followed the government recipes. None of them were harder to make than a bologna sandwich.
大约在这个时候，我们也开始对烟火非常着迷。我们从鞭炮毕业到莫洛托夫鸡尾酒、自制凝固汽油弹和管状炸弹。我们弄到了一对中央情报局（CIA）的炸弹手册，就照着政府的配方做了。没有哪个做起来比做一个博洛尼亚香肠三明治更难。
At this stage, most of our pranks were property crimes. We blew up mailboxes. We tried to demolish a local monument, a real eyesore.
在这个阶段，我们的大多数恶作剧都是财产犯罪。我们炸毁了邮箱。我们试图拆毁一个当地的纪念碑，那真是个碍眼的东西。
Even these early pranks didn't sit too well with me, but I kept my mouth shut. We had adopted this sort of punk rock pose that didn't give a rip about society or other people's feelings. Decent was suspect. Philip remembers the following scenario.
即使这些早期的恶作剧让我感到不安，但我还是闭上了嘴。我们采纳了一种朋克摇滚姿态，不在乎社会或其他人的感受。体面是令人怀疑的。菲利普记得以下情景。
There was an overpass. Actually, it was a bridge. And it overlooked the water. And we had this idea of throwing rocks off the overpass onto passing boats. So we did that, attempting to hit a boat that was passing underneath. And I don't even know if we hit it or not. We couldn't tell because it was so far down.
有一个立交桥。实际上，那是一座桥。它俯瞰着水面。我们有一个想法，从立交桥上往过往的船只扔石头。所以我们就这么做了，试图击中一艘经过下方的船。我甚至不知道我们是否击中了它。我们看不出来，因为它太远了。
But when we started arguing about whether that was a good idea or not, I was telling Gordon, "I just have a feeling. This guy working on his boat every weekend to try to make it polished and beautiful. And takes it out for an afternoon, and we drop a rock on it. That's just evil." And Gordon looking at me and saying, "Philip, I'm really concerned that you care at all about this person. I'm concerned that you have empathy for this person."
但当我们开始争论这是否是个好主意时，我告诉戈登：“我只是有种感觉。这个人在每个周末都在努力修理他的船，想让它看起来光亮又漂亮。他开出去一个下午，我们就往上面扔石头。那真是太邪恶了。”戈登看着我说：“菲利普，我真的担心你竟然会关心这个人。我担心你会对这个人产生同情。”
One point I should make is that I'd never really had friends before. These were my first friends, and I was glad to have them. Didn't know how I got them, but intended to keep them. Once the pranking started, there was this slow pull, this strong, slow pull towards the most extreme acts we could imagine. It was like the pranks had their own logic that pulled us further and further.
我应该指出的重点是，我以前从没有过朋友。这是我的第一批朋友，我很高兴拥有他们。不知道我怎么得到他们的，但打算留住他们。一旦恶作剧开始，就有一种缓慢的拉力，一种强烈的、缓慢的拉力，把我们推向我们能想象到的最极端的行为。就像这些恶作剧有它们自己的逻辑，把我们推得越来越远。
It starts out with these common, little pranks that are fun and creative. And then, for some reason, it gets darker. And we are pushing each other further. We had done some pretty bad stuff. And it was just this one-upmanship attitude, where we were just trying to think of what would be the next bad thing that we could do.
它开始于那些常见的小恶作剧，它们既有趣又有创造力。然后，出于某种原因，它变得更阴暗了。我们互相推动着走得更远。我们做了一些相当糟糕的事情。这只是一种好胜的心理，我们在想下一个我们可以做的糟糕事情是什么。
And Chris came up with this idea. And he said, "You know, guys, I got an idea." Oh, when you-- thinking about the fact that we did these things is just-- Chris looked at us and said, "There's a black family that lives down the street. Let's go to their house and write 'nigger' on their door."
然后克里斯提出了这个想法。他说：“嘿，伙计们，我有个主意。”噢，当你……想到我们做了这些事情，真是……克里斯看着我们说：“住在那条街的那一家黑人。我们去他们家，在门上写上‘黑鬼’（nigger）。”
And none of us were racist. And none of us were white supremists. And none of us had any political motivation about anything like that. It just seemed like just the most anti-social thing we could do.
我们中没有人是种族主义者。我们中没有人是白人至上主义者。我们中也没有人有关于那之类的政治动机。这看起来似乎只是我们能做的最反社会的事情。
I know this sounds god awful. Of course, it does. This time it was Gordon's turn to try and squash a really bad idea. He stood up to Chris, which was almost inconceivable because he was like our alpha male. And Chris backed down.
我知道这听起来简直糟糕透顶。当然是这样。这一次轮到戈登试图压制这个极其糟糕的想法。他站起来反对克里斯，这几乎是不可想象的，因为他就像我们的头号老大。克里斯退缩了。
But Chris was the driving force behind our biggest property crime, the local power plant. It happened one night when the five of us were in Gordon's pickup truck. In the back were a couple lengths of heavy chain. Gordon and Jack tell the story.
但克里斯是我们最大财产犯罪的推动力，目标是当地的发电厂。那是有一天晚上，我们五个人坐在戈登的皮卡车里发生的。后面装着几段沉重的铁链。戈登和杰克讲述了这个故事。
Chris was in the back of the truck. And he saw these chains. And as we were driving by the power plant, he had the idea that we should go and try to blow it up.
克里斯在卡车后面。他看到了这些链子。当我们经过发电厂时，他有一个想法，我们应该去试图炸掉它。
I remember Chris took the chain, which was the bigger of the two, and looped it in half and just tried to wing it over the fence at one of the transformers.
我记得克里斯拿起那条较大的铁链，对折，试图把它扔到围栏上面去接触其中一个变压器。
And honestly, I didn't think that-- I thought this was a futile effort. I didn't think that it was going to do anything.
老实说，我没认为——我以为这是一种徒劳的努力。我不认为它会造成什么后果。
I couldn't have been looking directly at it when it connected, when the chain connected with the transformer. And I was blinded for a minute there. And the next thing I noticed was how dark it was in that already dark, rural area. But it was so dark because every street light was out. Every house light was out. It was real dark.
我不可能在它连接的时候直视它，当链子连接上变压器的时候。那一刻我眼盲了一分钟。接下来我注意到的是，在这个本来就黑暗的农村地区变得有多么黑。它是那么黑，因为每一盏路灯都熄灭了。每一盏房灯都熄灭了。真的很黑。
That's when the fear set in on me. I thought, "I really want to get out of here because whatever we've done, it's serious. And this is really bad."
那是恐惧袭上我心头的时候。我想：“我真的想离开这里，因为无论我们做了什么，它都很严重。这真的很糟糕。”
All I remember is Chris begging us to get going. "Let's get going." I don't remember anyone saying that they felt bad for having done untold-- I don't know how much damage-- how much that would have cost to repair. That must have been huge. But yeah, I certainly don't remember anybody expressing any remorse for it.
我只记得克里斯乞求我们赶快离开。“我们走吧。”我不记得有谁说他们因为做了不可估量的——我不知道那是多少损失——不知道修复它需要多少钱。那一定是个巨额数字。但是是的，我当然不记得有任何人对此表示懊悔。
And the whole way back, we were just talking about how crazy it was, and how people on life support systems could be suffocating, and that kind of thing. It was exciting.
回来的路上，我们一直在谈论它有多疯狂，靠生命维持系统的人可能会窒息，诸如此类的事情。那很令人兴奋。
I point out here that most of us weren't seen as problem kids. When I wasn't out with my friends, I collected Chinese stamps, went to Hebrew school, practiced the viola, not that a sociopath can't play the viola. Then there came this point when their talk about pranks, if you could still call them that, shifted from property to people. This was the beginning of the end of us as a group of friends. Here are Philip and Jack.
我在此指出，我们大多数人并不被视为问题少年。当我不和朋友们出去的时候，我收集中国邮票，去希伯来学校，练习中提琴，并不是说反社会者就不能拉中提琴。然后出现了一个转折点，他们关于恶作剧的谈论，如果你还能称之为恶作剧的话，从财产转移到了人。这是我们作为朋友团体的终结的开始。这是菲利普和杰克。
We were trying to decide one evening what would be our next step in what we were going to be doing violent-wise. And objects-- destroying public property or private property was just not exciting enough anymore. And so we went out one night. We were driving around downtown. And we saw this staggering drunk.
一天晚上我们试图决定在暴力方面我们的下一步行动是什么。而物体——破坏公共财产或私人财产已经不再令人兴奋了。所以有一天晚上我们出去了。我们开车在市中心转悠。我们看到了一个步履蹒跚的醉汉。
And Chris got out of the car with his Taser. And he was acting really sweet to this guy and just chatting with him, being chummy. And the guy was smiling. And then Chris took the Taser out of his pocket or wherever and showed it to him.
克里斯拿着他的电击枪下了车。他表现得对那个家伙很友善，和他聊天，套近乎。那个人笑了。然后克里斯从口袋里还是哪儿把电击枪拿出来给他看。
And he said, "Look at this. Do you know what this is?" The guy shook his head. "Well, it's for doing this." And he put the Taser on the guy's arm or something. And it didn't knock him down. But it was, obviously, extremely painful. And the guy shrieked and pulled away.
他说：“看看这个。你知道这是什么吗？”那人摇了摇头。“好吧，它是用来做这个的。”他把电击枪放在那人的手臂上或其他地方。它没有把他击倒。但显然非常痛苦。那个人尖叫着躲开了。
There was another time when Chris attacked a vagrant that mirrored a scene from the film A Clockwork Orange, which we watched and rewatched during those years.
还有一次，克里斯袭击了一个流浪汉，这镜像了电影《发条橙》（A Clockwork Orange）中的一个场景，我们在那几年里看了又看这部电影。
He kicked him. I remember. And he did it in this overly dramatic way. And I remember laughing.
我记得他踢了他。而且他踢得非常戏剧化。我记得我在笑。
We were all exhilarated, and we were all laughing. I think we were in awe of what we had done. But because we didn't know how to talk about it, we were just laughing.
我们都感到兴奋，我们都在笑。我想我们被我们所做的事情惊呆了。但因为我们不知道该如何谈论它，所以我们只是在笑。
And then all of a sudden, I realized how twisted all that was.
然后突然间，我意识到这一切有多扭曲。
I was there in the car for the first of these incidents. I remember feeling trapped. I remember wanting out. That was it for me. I dumped my friends. I was surprised to hear it wasn't long after that everyone left for the same reason. The strange thing was that each of us thought he was the only one who reacted adversely to this new violence, that the others somehow enjoyed it.
这些事件发生时，我第一次就在车里。我记得感觉被困住了。我记得我想逃出去。对我来说就到此为止了。我甩掉了我的朋友们。我很惊讶听到不久之后，大家也因为同样的原因离开了。奇怪的是，我们每个人都以为只有自己对这种新的暴力行为有反感，而其他人却以某种方式享受它。
When I started to hear about the Littleton shootings and when I started to hear about the shooters, the kind of kids they were, I found myself thinking about this ugly slice of my personal past, things I hadn't thought about in years. I found myself asking questions about who we were exactly. Here's Jack.
当我开始听到利特尔顿枪击事件，当我开始听到枪手们的故事，他们是那种什么样的孩子时，我发现自己在想我个人历史中这段丑陋的片段，那些我多年来从未想过的事情。我发现自己在问我们到底是谁。这是杰克。
I turn on the TV, and I saw what was happening at Littleton and the descriptions of the kids that were coming out to the media were-- I remember thinking, "My god, that was us."
我打开电视，看到利特尔顿发生的事情，媒体报道出来的关于那些孩子的描述——我记得我当时想：“我的天，那就是我们。”
This is Philip.
这是菲利普。
When I first heard about Littleton, there were these kids in trench coats. And I wore a trench coat. And there were these kids that called themselves The Trench Coat Mafia. And I don't think we had a name for ourselves, but we had that attitude. And I won't go so far as to say, "It could have been me." Because I never would have killed anybody. Maybe.
当我第一次听到利特尔顿事件时，有那些穿着风衣的孩子。我也穿过风衣。还有那些自称“风衣黑手党”的孩子。我不认为我们给自己取过名字，但我们有那种态度。我不会说“那本来可能是我”。因为我永远不会杀任何人。也许。
Definitely, I remember thinking that it's way too close to home.
但我确实记得我认为它太接近家了。
Philip.
菲利普。
I don't think there's any difference between what they did in Littleton and what we were doing. When Eric Harris decided to take a gun to school and kill his classmates, he was thinking the exact same way we were when we decided to stay out at night and mash people's mailboxes. Or when we decided to take that monument and destroy it. It was that same anger, inarticulate anger.
我不认为他们在利特尔顿所做的事情和我们在做的事情之间有什么区别。当埃里克·哈里斯决定带着枪去学校杀害他的同学时，他思考的方式和我们在决定晚上呆在外面去捣毁人们的邮箱时，或者在我们决定拆毁那个纪念碑时，是完全一样的。那是同样的愤怒，一种无法表达的愤怒。
Here's Gordon.
这是戈登。
I guess in some sense, what we were doing wasn't all that different. They took it way further, way, way further than we would. What they did was inconceiveable to us. But I suppose, if the circumstances in my life were a little different, I suppose that I could have walked over that line. But the circumstances of my life weren't that extreme.
我想从某种意义上说，我们所做的事情并没有什么不同。他们走得远得多，比我们远得多。他们所做的事情对我们来说是不可想象的。但我想，如果我生活中的情况稍微不同一些，我想我可能会越过那条线。但我生活的情况没有那么极端。
How are we supposed to think about Littleton? And how are my friends and I supposed to think about the awful things we did as kids? I usually hear people talk in two different ways about the kinds of trouble teenagers get into. Either they see it as a kind of innocent boys-will-be-boys joyride. Or they see it as social pathology. And they feel they have come down on one side or the other. Based on personal experience, I think I can say, it's a little of both.
我们应该如何看待利特尔顿？我的朋友和我应该如何看待我们小时候做过的那些可怕的事情？我通常听到人们以两种不同的方式谈论青少年参与的这类麻烦。要么他们将其视为一种天真的“男孩就是男孩”的兜风，要么他们将其视为社会病态。他们觉得必须站在这一边或那一边。基于个人经验，我想说，这既有一点这一面，也有一点那一面。
Paul Bravmann is a freelance writer living in New York City.
保罗·布拉夫曼是一位居住在纽约市的自由撰稿人。
[MUSIC - "TOO SWEET TO DIE" BY THE WACO BROTHERS]
[音乐 - 韦科兄弟的“TOO SWEET TO DIE”]
Act Four, When We Were Angels. Let us end our program today with an example of the most innocent childhood prank, the most innocent student uprising imaginable. Hillary Frank is in graduate school, studying drawing at the New York Academy of Art. A few months ago, she mailed our radio show a story that she wanted to get onto the program.
第四幕，当我们是天使时。让我们用一个最天真的童年恶作剧例子来结束我们今天的节目，这是可以想象到的最天真的学生起义。希拉里·弗兰克（Hillary Frank）正在纽约艺术学院读研究生，学习绘画。几个月前，她寄给我们广播节目一个她想加入节目的故事。
She had recorded the interviews using her microcassette answering machine. And then she edited the interviews and recorded the parts that she said, her script, by dubbing and recording onto her shiny, red boombox. For all the crude sound quality, the story sounded remarkably like a story on This American Life. But for one reason or another, and time considerations, that unsolicited story never made it onto the radio.
她用微型卡带答录机录制了采访。然后她通过配音并将她说的部分——她的剧本——录制到她那闪亮的红色手提音响上，剪辑了这些采访。尽管声音质量很粗糙，但这个故事听起来非常像《美国生活》中的一个故事。但由于某种原因和时间限制，那个主动投递的故事从未在广播中播出。
This week, though, she has put together another story using the same style, which we added music to here at the radio station to make it fully sound like a story on our show. It is about an incident which happened to her back when she was an undergraduate.
不过这周，她用同样的风格整理了另一个故事，我们在这里的广播电台加入了音乐，使它听起来完全像我们节目的故事。这是关于她本科时代发生在她身上的一件事。
Tufts University is a pretty straight place. Entertainment for most people means fraternity keggers. It's not the sort of place you'd expect people to watch a guy sitting on another guy's shoulders pretending to be a giant. It happened by accident in 1994. My friend, Scott, was the top half.
塔夫茨大学（Tufts University）是一个非常正统的地方。对大多数人来说，娱乐意味着兄弟会的啤酒派对。那不是你会期望人们看到一个人骑在另一个人肩膀上假装成巨人的地方。这在1994年是一次意外发生的。我的朋友斯科特（Scott）是上半身。
It was beginning of the school year. And we were bored one night. And we decided to go up to the quad. And I guess, basically, Jeff got up on someone's back. And he started yelling and screaming about how giant he was and how magnificent he was. And I think, actually, right after that, I might have gotten on someone's back and said, "Yeah, I'm also giant."
那是学年开始的时候。有一天晚上我们很无聊。我们决定去方庭（Quad）。我想，基本上，杰夫（Jeff）骑在某人背上。他开始大喊大叫，说他是多么巨大，多么壮观。我想，其实就在那之后，我也可能骑在某人背上说：“是的，我也是巨人。”
And I guess that really struck a chord in me. I thought that was pretty amusing. I guess I thought a lot about it. It actually did start me thinking along a particular path.
我想那真的触动了我的心弦。我觉得那很有趣。我想我想了很多。它确实让我开始沿着特定的路径思考。
Scott talked about the idea one night in the dining hall. The next day, on the way to class, he saw signs all over campus that said in bold print, "I am nine feet tall. Come see Giantman. 8:00 PM on the quad."
斯科特有一天晚上在餐厅里谈论了这个想法。第二天，在去上课的路上，他看到校园里到处都是用粗体字写的标语，上面写着：“我九英尺高。来看巨人侠（Giantman）。晚上8点在方庭。”
Scott had no idea who put them up. He learned later that the signs were posted by a guy who had overheard him talking at dinner. Scott decided he would go to the quad at the specified time and undertake the challenge. To pull this off, he would need to create a character and a costume for the giant. He gave Giantman a booming voice.
斯科特不知道是谁贴的。他后来得知这些标志是由一个在餐厅偷听他谈话的人贴的。斯科特决定在指定的时间去方庭接受挑战。为了完成这件事，他需要为这个巨人创造一个角色和一套服装。他给了巨人侠一个响亮的声音。
I don't even know exactly. It was something like, "Behold, I am giant." Not even loud, but just weird and suggesting man-ness in a vague way. I don't know.
我甚至不知道具体是什么。大概是这样：“看哪，我是巨人。”甚至不是大声，只是很奇怪，以一种模糊的方式暗示人的存在。我不知道。
Scott asked his tallest friend, Podo, to act as Giantman's legs. They grabbed some props before heading up to the quad, a blanket to wrap around their middle to hide Podo, a long wooden staff, and a black, curly wig, like the guys in Kiss.
斯科特请他最高的伙伴波多（Podo）担任巨人侠的双腿。他们在前往方庭之前抓了一些道具：一条裹在中间遮住波多的毯子、一根木制长棍，还有一个像Kiss乐队那种黑色的卷发假发。
We had picked a point in the bushes, Podo and I. We really couldn't see what was going on out on the quad. And so the time came, and I got on his shoulders, basically, and tied the blanket around my waist. And we walked out.
波多和我选了一个灌木丛中的地点。我们真的看不见方庭外面发生了什么。时间到了，我基本上骑在他肩膀上，把毯子系在腰间。我们就走了出来。
And I remember there just being maybe 10 people, 15 people. And I remember them being way on the other side and running. What was so ridiculous about it was there was just a handful of people, and they were so spread out. But they were all coming towards me. It was like, what the hell am I doing here?
我记得大概只有10个人、15个人。我记得他们远远地在另一边跑着。可笑的是，只有那么几个人，而且他们分散得很开。但他们都朝着我走来。那就像是，我到底在这里干什么？
They decided to plan another Giantman appearance the following week. They posted more signs and told everyone they knew, "Go see Giantman. It'll blow your mind." Word spread quickly. And amazingly, they were able to keep it secret that they, themselves, were Giantman. Most students believed there was an actual nine-foot man come to Tufts for some mysterious reason. I was friends with these guys, and I didn't even know yet.
他们决定在接下来的一周安排另一次巨人侠露面。他们贴了更多的标语并告诉他们认识的每个人：“去看看巨人侠。这会让你大开眼界。”消息传得很快。令人惊奇的是，他们能够保密自己就是巨人侠。大多数学生相信真的有一个九英尺高的人因为某种神秘的原因来到塔夫茨。我当时是这些家伙的朋友，我甚至还不知道。
At the next appearance, almost 200 people were waiting for Giantman and chanting his name. It was like a political rally. Some of them carried signs that said things like, "We love you Giantman. Why are you here?" "Save us from ourselves, Giantman." "Nine feet of loving." And "Giant freak, go home."
在下一次露面时，有近200人等待着巨人侠并齐声呼喊他的名字。那就像一场政治集会。有些人带着标语，上面写着诸如：“我们爱你巨人侠。你为什么在这里？”“从我们自己手中拯救我们吧，巨人侠。”“九英尺的爱。”还有“巨人怪胎，回家去吧。”
Giantman made his way onto the quad, and the quad went wild. People came rushing out of their dorms to see what was going on. When Giantman reached his fans, he made a small speech. "I am giant," he boomed. "I am huge, and I have brought you butterscotch." He then threw cellophane-wrapped butterscotch to the crowd, and they dove for it.
巨人侠走上方庭，方庭沸腾了。人们从宿舍里冲出来看发生了什么。当巨人侠到达他的粉丝面前时，他做了一个简短的演讲。“我是巨人，”他轰隆着说。“我是巨大的，我带给了你们奶油糖果。”然后他把用玻璃纸包裹的奶油糖果扔向人群，他们扑向糖果。
On the walk up, I just stopped in the bookstore and saw some candy. And I was trying to think, "What was the most ridiculous candy that nobody every ate?" There was butterscotch there in some kind of cellophane wrapper. It looked like nobody ever was eating it.
在走上去的时候，我正好经过书店，看到了一些糖果。我试图思考，“什么是没有人会吃的、最荒谬的糖果？”那里有一些用玻璃纸包装的奶油糖果。看起来好像没人会吃它。
Butterscotch became Giantman's trademark treat. When he ran out of things to say, he would revert to throwing candy. The fact of the matter is Giantman had very little to tell the Tufts community other than "My strength is amazing. My girth is enormous. And my height is unequaled." He would brag like this for only two or three minutes and then retreat back to the bushes.
奶油糖果成了巨人侠的标志性零食。当他不知道说什么的时候，他就会回到扔糖果的老路上。事实是，巨人侠除了“我的力量是惊人的。我的体型是巨大的。我的身高是无与伦比的”之外，几乎没什么能告诉塔夫茨社区的。他会像这样吹牛两三分钟，然后撤回到灌木丛中。
Problem was, Podo would get really tired really quickly. He walked out really fast. He almost was running out. And he got really tired and didn't even know where he was going. It must have just looked absolutely idiotic.
问题是，波多会很快变得非常累。他走得非常快。他几乎是在跑。他变得非常累，甚至不知道他要去哪儿。那看起来一定绝对像个白痴。
So he couldn't see?
所以他看不见？
Yeah, his eyes were covered. I remember I would sit on his head, and I would put both my hands on his head, kind of give him direction by maybe forcing his head in a certain direction.
是的，他的眼睛被遮住了。我记得我会坐在他的头上，我会把双手放在他的头上，通过用力强迫他的头向某个方向转动来给他指引。
Giantman became a phenomenon. Enthusiasts wore "I love Giantman" t-shirts, which had silhouettes of a huge man with a bulging middle. There was once a parade across campus with noise makers and a trumpet to greet him. Another time, there were torch jugglers and bodyguards. Letters were written to the student newspaper pro and con Giantman. Teachers were mentioning Giantman in class. There was a discussion in an ethics course in which people who hadn't seen Giantman argued about whether or not we were exploiting a freak of nature.
巨人侠成了一个现象。爱好者穿着“我爱巨人侠”的T恤，上面有一个巨大且中间隆起的人的剪影。校园里曾经举行过一次游行，有发声器和喇叭来迎接他。还有一次，有喷火杂耍者和保镖。给学生报纸写信的人有支持也有反对巨人侠的。老师们在课上也提到了巨人侠。在伦理学课程中有一场讨论，那些没见过巨人侠的人争论我们是否在利用一个自然的怪胎。
Do you think that if Giantman had been an actual political cause that you would have gotten such a big turnout and there would have been such a big deal about it?
你认为如果巨人侠是一个实际的政治事业，你是否会得到这么大的反响，并且人们会对此大惊小怪吗？
Yeah, I doubt that. That's one of the things, I think, that was a big draw about it was that it didn't have any meaning. And for whatever reason, people were really drawn to that. If it had meaning or was trying to pitch some idea or something, it would seem less real, I think. There was really something fundamentally interesting and truthful about Giantman, I guess. There is something that people are drawn to that absurdity for whatever reason.
是的，我怀疑。我想那正是吸引力很大的原因之一，因为它没有任何意义。不管出于什么原因，人们确实被这一点吸引了。如果它有意义或试图推销某种想法或类似的东西，我想它看起来就不会那么真实了。我想巨人侠确实有一些根本上有趣且真实的东西。有一些东西让人们出于某种原因被那种荒谬所吸引。
By the end, Giantman's following had grown to about 350 people. I don't think any of us have had any experience like it since. When you're a student, it still feels like something exciting might happen at any moment. Life feels full of all this potential. But when you get out of school, that potential just doesn't seem to be there.
最后，巨人侠的追随者增加到了大约350人。我不认为我们中任何人在那之后还有过类似的经历。当你是一个学生时，依然感觉任何时候都可能发生令人兴奋的事情。生活感觉充满了这种潜力。但当你走出学校，这种潜力似乎就不复存在了。
What do you know now?
你现在知道什么？
Well, I'm an engineer.
好吧，我是一名工程师。
What kind of engineer?
什么样的工程师？
Computer engineer, designing computer circuits and things like that.
计算机工程师，设计计算机电路等等。
And do you have Giantman-like experiences today?
你今天还有像巨人侠那样的经历吗？
No, not really. I'm not parading around, talking about my magnificence.
不，真的没有。我没有到处游行，谈论我的壮观。
There's actually a recording of Giantman's final public appearance. There was a band called The Electric Fun Machine that dedicated a song to him. And he appeared with them at a concert on the quad.
其实有巨人侠最后一次公开露面的录音。有一个乐队叫“电动乐趣机器”（The Electric Fun Machine），他们为他献上了一首歌。他在方庭的音乐会上与他们一起出现。
[SINGING] The Giantman. Giantman. Nine feet tall. Giantman.
[歌唱] 巨人侠。巨人侠。九英尺高。巨人侠。
Students of Tufts, fear me not for I am the benevolent Giantman. I have come to show love. As a symbol of my benevolence, I shall, once again, shower you with--
塔夫茨的学生们，不要怕我，因为我是仁慈的巨人侠。我来是为了展现爱。作为我仁慈的象征，我将再次让你们沉浸在——
And then Giantman threw butterscotch candy.
然后巨人侠扔出了奶油糖果。
Hillary Frank in New York.
希拉里·弗兰克，纽约。
A program note. Producer Alix Spiegel leaves our program today, and producer Nancy Updike goes to half-time for a few months, and then she will also leave, which means that this program is the last one made by the team that has done most episodes of This American Life since it began in 1995, the team of Elise, and Nancy, and our third producer, Julie Snyder. For me, I have to say, it is like knowing that Michael Jordan, Scottie Pippen, and Dennis Rodman will never play together again. They are each amazing in their own way. And they are more amazing together.
节目预告。制作人阿利克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）今天离开了我们的节目，制作人南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）将在几个月内转为半职，然后她也会离开，这意味着本期节目是自1995年以来制作大部分《美国生活》剧集的团队制作的最后一期，即埃莉斯（Elise）、南希和我们的第三位制作人朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）组成的团队。对我来说，我必须说，这就像知道迈克尔·乔丹、斯科蒂·皮蓬和丹尼斯·罗德曼永远不会再一起打球了一样。他们每个人都有自己的惊人之处。而他们在一起时更是惊人。
This show that you hear on the radio every week is not mine. It is ours, the four of ours. I'm the front man, but the sensibility of the show is the four of ours. As you might expect, getting a radio program on the air each week is a little battle. And we feel about each other the way that any people who have been together in the trenches feel, namely, bonded for life.
你每周在广播里听到的这个节目不是我一个人的。它是我们的，我们四个人的。我是前台，但节目的感性是属于我们四个人的。正如你可能预料的那样，每周让一个广播节目上台是一场小小的战斗。我们对彼此的感觉，就像任何在战壕里共同战斗过的人一样，即终身捆绑。
We created this thing together, this show that has become so much larger than the sum of its parts. And we will always have that together. Nancy and Elise are both skilled reporters. You  will hear them here and, I expect, on other public radio shows, though I have to say, I will miss the time that we have had together very much. It has been a very unusual and a very lucky thing, this time we've had together.
我们一起创造了这个东西，这个节目已经变得远比其部分的总和还要大。我们将永远一起拥有它。南希和埃莉斯都是技术娴熟的记者。你会在这里听到她们，我想也会在其他公共广播节目中听到，尽管我不得不说，我会非常想念我们在一起度过的时光。这是非常不寻常且非常幸运的事情，我们在一起的这段时光。
So This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
所以《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。